je vous l'avais promis c'est à dire
qu'on est avec nous ça va bien installé
à genève et à juste d'arriver bien sûr
le temps de s'installer
vous avez été plébiscités sur deux boys
mais éliminé avec cette magnifique
chanson que tout le monde adore à will
always love you man et qu'il s'en sorte
on fera le débat thaler avec avec c'est
parce qu'il ya eu une polémique puisque
à part vous a été coupée au montage on
n'en parle pas maintenant mais ce qu'on
voulait c'était vous l'entendre chanter
parce que tu as une voix magnifique et
surtout vous avez chanté une chanson de
vous écrire pour vous paroles et musique
exactement le plateau est à vous comme
dirait je ne sais pas qui je vous en
prie alors c'est pas le droit c'est la
première chanson que j'ai écrit et
compose à la suite de l'histoire qu'on
aura l'occasion de titres de moquer de
tout à l'heure exactement ce que des
paroles mois
j'ai pas le droit de thé mais simplement
mais malgré tout je te comprend sept
gens dont tu m'as parlé pour toi la
famille labbé des cités tu avais tant de
fois déjà essayé de vaincre le sommet
le sang à parler plus fort
c'est ta réalité désillusion ton
imagination telle émotion mais
t'as pas le droit
[Musique]
j'ai pas le droit ça je l' ai bien
compris et ja
l'art dans mon ennui que là
visible évidence marque pour
le temps de latence pourtant peu âme
décline le feu dans tes yeux
je salue
appelez moi qui ai pas
[Musique]
celle la réalité désillusion père
imagination sable émotions mais
pas le droit
[Applaudissements]
c'est la réalité désillusion pure
imagination simple émotion
le droit
et
j'ai pas le droit de crier ma rage seul
dans la nuit
j'espère un miracle même
si ce n'est qu'un mirage ma foi peu
détruire les obstacles ce n'est
à la raison qui m je suis peut-être fort
mais
jallet
c'est ma réalité mes illusions mon
imagination mais
mention mais j'ai pas le droit
c'est ma réalité mes illusions mon
imagination mes émotions
j'ai pas le droit
[Musique]
et à moi non c'est alors alors alors
bravo bravo tv alors à vos fêtes alors
c'est pas de doux des lieux dédiés à
vous c'est juste le débrief de ce
qu'elle a vécu son plateau de devrez
aussi vous avez pu écouter mon cher ami
c'est aussi beaucoup